[Musique]
hier donald trump était en californie un
état ravagés par des incendies
historique depuis plus d'une semaine le
bilan est lourd 27 morts ces derniers
jours et face à des élus locaux qui a
affirmé que ce n'était pas juste des
incendies de forêt mais des incendies
climatique
il faut savoir que les 50 degrés ont été
dépassées la semaine dernière à los
angeles par exemple alors que le
gouverneur de la région et des experts
scientifiques tentent d'expliquer au
président les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique sur les
incendies donald trump ballet leurs
inquiétudes d'une façon surprenante et
l'austral câline course a commencé à se
refroidir je suis fils attendre ou soit
à websense équipe avant d'ajouter je ne
pense pas que la science sache
réellement la ps qui tue un tiers de
perdre de deux personnes en europe c'est
sympa ouais ça nous rappelle une autre
époque qui finalement n'aurait ça nous
renvoie la pandémie c'est vrai aussi que
régulièrement l'histoire des soeurs se
répète pas mais elle bégaye quoi il ya
des mais ça s'arrête et on sait jamais
trop pourquoi donc espérons que ça
s'arrête
ouais ou c'est vrai qu'on s'en fout
dehors pourquoi se tendent avec le co
vite va durer il faut tous lucides là
dessus pas la peine de se mentir je
pense que dans cette capacité qu'on a à
se projeter se réinventer dans le ce
moment ce qu'on a appelé le monde
d'après mais qui va être au fond le
monde de la vie avec le virus sans doute
pour ed semestre peut-être des années et
surtout la bonne soirée
personne ne pourra aller aussi loin que
les indonésiens alors eux ils laissent
tomber
l'investissement de l'espace
publicitaire et investissent l'espace
public avec dans les rues de djakarta
des cercueils qui sont installés comme
ça sur les carrefours pour montrer où
peut mener le non-respect des gestes
barrières et on vient d'apprendre
d'ailleurs que huit citoyens ont été
enquêtés des menus de masques ont été
condamnés à croiser les tombes
sachez qu'au canada le port du masque
est suggérée pour certains couples
pendant le sexe notre recommandation
réduit réduit son nouveau à l'image on
réduit son nombre de partenaires ça
c'est une autre préconisation il est
recommandé de bien se laver les dents
les deux ans par dont vous pouvez laver
c'est bien aussi un les bras au jeu
avant d'arriver il m'a dit si tu gagnes
20000 on se marie donc j là il s'empale
mec donc la pression quoi sert y a que
l'argent qui m'intéresse
owen teganya je te quitte
ils n'en n'ont pas dormi de la nuit le
1er septembre ce couple alsacien a vu sa
vie basculer 157 millions d'euros d'un
coup de baguette magique
j'avais l'impression d'être cendrillon
avec l'espoir que tout cela était bien
réel et que le carrosse ne se transforme
pas en citrouille à minuit
le conte de fée se réalise pourtant bien
les deux heureux joueurs occasionnels
empoche ainsi le troisième plus gros
jackpot de la loterie européenne pour
leur mettre l'eau à la bouche ils
pourront par exemple vivre plus de 43
ans dans la suite royale du plus beaux
palaces au monde le burj al arab de
dubaï partir sur la mer en achetant le
dixième yacht le plus cher du monde
estimé à 150 millions de dollars ou
encore s'envoyer en l'air à bord d'un
vol à destination de la lune au moins
600 28 fois dans leur vie
on va aller dans la montagne on va mener
une vie de berger
c'est le thème une vie de bergie ça vous
dit
l'hébergeur peut-être cher
je craque trouver des émoticônes dans
une forêt c'est comme chercher une
aiguille dans une meule est une fois
puissant très contente et très
confortable très confortable avance
avait comme fauteuil de bureau mais
c'est un petit coussin de sous quand
même là ça vous oblige à rester
concentré sur le travail aux l'animal à
vous entendez sérieuses commencent pour
sa soupe on se concentre sa pipe est un
peu les fesses et donc on reste on reste
actif ces douleurs sont à bout et tout
une partie très intime de notre notre
anatomie peuvent parfois s'avérer
gênante voire handicapante fissures
hémorroïdes abcès il ne faut pas
souffrir en silence
aujourd'hui est le docteur est consacrée
aux douleurs de l'anus alors j'ai un
petit problème je suis obligé de vous le
montrer parce qu'ils se moquent de moi
qu'est-ce qui se passe non je vais vous
montrer parce que ma venue ternir le
tonnerre
mais c'est sexy quelqu'un qui porte un
jeans samuil le paquet le panier le
burrito les parties intimes des hommes
et des femmes
quoi de plus efficace pour encadrer son
derrière qu'un beau jeans
[Applaudissements]
est ce que ça existe encore bien vide on
attend cette fête
olala malien plastique là alors tu es
allé casser complètement séché un cas
c'est un holà la vérité c'est que la
france
rios et d'étendre son adn c'est percuté
de l'intérieur
c'est ça que vous ne voulez pas admettre
qu est ce que vous me parlez des pays
émergents c'est pas ça le rapport les
genres le sentiment en france
aujourd'hui ils ont le sens d'un déclin
les personnels de d'une france qui tombe
et vous me parlez des pays émergents
vous êtes déconnecté de ses 78 % des
gens c'est tout ce que je vous dis 55%
c'est la part de la population qui
serait favorable au rétablissement de la
peine de mort c'est ce que révèle un
sondage ipsos dévoilé hier
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant le
confinement ils ont regardé louis de
funès matin midi et soir et alors il
trouve que c'est mieux
j'ai vu de lui donner crédit ils ont
trouvé que la france des années 70 ce
qui les fait rêver c'est quoi à l'époque
l'accessoire à voir absolument pour la
rentrée scolaire
j'imagine que s'il dit 12 grammes de
shit on va me couper donc on va dire à
sac d'une marque particulière ou des
chaussures ou un ballon foot 9
j'ai décidé et c'est ça l'information je
vous donnais de changer de rythme et de
transmettre le flambeau du journal dès
la fin de cette année je sais que ma
décision d'arrêter le trésor va
surprendre pas mal d'entre vous je les
murs montrait mûrement réfléchie de 13h
et moi c'est une aventure vraiment
extraordinaire grâce à vous grâce à
votre confiance à celle de vos parents
et vos grands parents parfois depuis
trente trois ans la grosse question
maintenant c'est là qui pour le
remplacer
alors plusieurs noms circulent les voici
on peut retirer jacques legros un pas
vraiment intéressé par le poste ou
darius rochebin qui reste sur lci il ya
dans le vivier
audrey crespo-mara pascal de la
tour-du-pin de la matinale ou encore
julien arnaud qui a déjà été joker de
perdre on a moins que je sais pas alors
qu'ils vont mettre pascal praud non je
ne pense pas c'est je refuserais moi je
suis bien ici
les indices des rumeurs et des rumeurs
on a toujours virer jean-pierre depuis
15 sur la vire et jean pierre est là
pour une fois c'est neil hannon sont
donc on vous a tous baiser je me suis
régalé c'était extraordinaire